des heures et même des jours.
Voici ce qu'a constaté
Sébastien Desrosiers.
- Chaque jour,
le même spectacle.
Des centaines de personnesattenr
leur passeport devant ce bureau
de Service Canada.
Mais les délais atteignent
des sommets.
Ça fait combien de temps
que vous attendez?
- Depuis 3 h du matin.
- La semaine dernière, elle
aurait été parmi les premiers
dans la file. Ces jours-ci,
il faut arriver encore plus tôts
combien de temps?
- Depuis 5 h hier soir.
- Ce groupe a dormi ici.
Ils ont pourtant fait
leur demande de passeport
il y a plus de deux mois.
Combien de gens il y avait
devant vous, hier, quand
vous êtes arrivés?
- On en a compté environ 140.
- Je suis arrivée hier
à 8 h du matin.
- À 8 h du matin?
- Oui, 8 h du matin.
- Oh!
Plus de 24 heures d'attente,
donc... Tous ces voyageurs
anxieux et parfois détrempés
partent d'ici lundi.
Certains se préparent à passer
une deuxième nuit à attendre.
- C'est trop long. Ça fait...
même pas aujourd'hui,
on peut être là, je pense.
On va attendre un autre jour
jusqu'à demain ça va être,
comme, 48 heures ici.
- Et tous ne voyagent pa
que pour les vacances.
- Je dois aller voir
mon grand-père en France,
qui a  d d d de nous voir
maintenant.
- Moi, je pars pour le mariage
de mes beaux-parents. Donc,
eux aussi sont en attente après
nous. Est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
y aller?
LUC BERTHOLD, chef adjoint,
Parterererervateur du Canada
- Quel ministre va se lever
pour prendre la responsabilité
pour ce chaos?
(applaudissements)
- La ministre responsabledededer
des critiques de plus en plus
dures.
ALAIN THERRIEN, leader
parlementaire, Bloc québécois
- Deux jours de file d'attente
pour obtenir un passeport parce
que ce gouvernement n'avait pas
prévu que voyager serait
populaire cet été!
KARINA GOULD, min., Famille,
Enfants et Développement social
- On comprend que les Canadiens
veulent voyager encore une fois,
mais la demande est vraiment
grande. On répond à ça.
- Alors, pour tenter de réduire
ces files d'attente, Service
Canada a engagé 600 nouveaux
employés depuis le début
de l'année, et est en voie
d'en engager 600 autres. Mais
est-ce que ce sera suffisant?
Force est de const
qu'obtenir son passeport est
toujours une véritable course
à obstacles.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Montréa